[Música]
eu sou mãe de um menino de 6 anos
chamado joão vicente e de uma menina de
2 anos e 7 meses chamada maria antônia
ea pergunta que eu mais escuto a
pergunta que mais me fazem é com a
diferença entre criar o menino e criar
uma menina ea minha resposta é sempre
muito imediata ela sempre a mesma eu
sempre falo pelo vejo diferença entre a
meninos e meninas
eu estou criando dois indivíduos
portanto cada um tem sua característica
essa é a resposta apesar de sempre a
mesma é uma mentira eu vejo diferença
entre a meninos e meninas
o gênero é uma questão porque quando
engravidei do meu filho eu fiquei muito
mas muito aliviada de saber que no meu
ventre tinha o homem porque eu tinha a
certeza que ele estaria livre de passar
por situações vivenciadas por nós
mulheres
teoricamente ele está livre
certo o errado é errado porque o meu
filho ele é um menino negro e liberdade
não é um direito que ele vai poder
usufruir se ele andar pelas ruas
descalço sem camisa
sujo saindo da aula de futebol ele corre
o risco de ser apontado como o fator
mesmo com seis anos de idade quando ele
se tornado adolescente ele não vai ter
liberdade de próxima escola pegar uma
condução pegar o ônibus com sua mochila
o seu boneco com seu capuz com o seu
andar adolescente sem correr o risco de
levar uma investida violento
para a polícia ao ser confundido com um
bandido porque no brasil a cor do meu
filho é a cor que faz com que as pessoas
mudem de calçada escondam suas bolsas e
que linda em seus carros
a vida dele só não vai ser mais difícil
do que é da minha filha maria antônio me
pego pensando o tempo inteiro quanto nós
mulheres somos criadas para agradar o
ponto no excellence ão e o ponto longe
se qualificam o tempo inteiro
quando eu penso o risco que ela corre
simplesmente por ter nascido mulher e
negra e vi completamente apavorada e o
meu pavor ele tem uma razão
observando o mapa da violência no brasil
esse mapa é de 2015 é o último que a
gente tem
os números são muito alarmantes mas nós
temos algumas vitórias muito poucas mas
eu queria ressaltar o humano é o número
de feminicídio contra mulheres brancas e
ele caiu
ele caiu 9,8 por cento
é muito pouco porque a gente deseja as
nossas mães brancas mas caiu
já o número de feminicídio contra as
mulheres negras aumentou 54,8 por cento
é ou não pra ficar apavorada se dizer
mais alguma coisa
preciso dizer que apesar do meu favor
apesar do meu medo apesar desses números
alarmantes
eu não ouso perder a esperança e fica
elaborando o tempo inteiro uma maneira
de eu criar meus filhos aqui no brasil
no meu país eu fico pensando como criar
crianças do assistir no país estão lá
sigo com crianças que acreditem que
pluralidade e diversidade são riquezas
no país que é tão plural que é tão
diverso e que é tão desigual como não
jogar sobre ela
uma vivência experiência alguma mágoa
que é minha mas também por não permitir
que elas enfrentem o mundo de maneira em
gelo para que não sejam atropelados pelo
racismo que existe na estrutura do nosso
país eu assistir um filme chamado 13ª
emenda o documentário ele fala sobre o
sistema carcerário norte americano ea
fala de rolim de um homem branco me
chamou muita atenção
ele disse eu sou fruto de uma escolha
feita pelos meus antepassados
os negros são fruto de uma falta de
possibilidade de escolha dos seus
antepassados
eu o lembrou quem ocupa essas escolhas
os negros contemporâneas têm culpa
dessas escolhas não longe de nós temos
culpa mas foi uma herança que a gente
recebeu então a gente tem que ter a
responsabilidade de lidar com essa
herança das quais são os frutos intenção
de pescar a favor eu falei gente que tá
falando
essa herança esse cara tá falando
ela tem um nome e ela se chama nossa
sociedade
sendo assim a desigualdade social
a desigualdade entre gêneros eo racismo
são sim problemas de todos nós e não é
só problema de gênero não porque até a
condição sexual importa muito nesse país
o brasil é o país que mais mata
homossexual no mundo
os meus filhos eles são crianças ainda
eu não sei qual será a posição sexual
deles mas o que desejo que eu desejo
para os meus filhos é o que desejo para
toda e qualquer criança seja branca
negra ou indígena não é heterossexual ou
homossexual e e trans
eu desejo que eles crianças são livres
cheio de amor coragem que sejam crianças
potentes e eu também tenho um sonho que
eu tenho um sonho
o dever ricos trabalhando pra acabar com
a pobreza de ver o homem se colocando no
lugar de mulheres de ver mulheres
brancas entendendo que existe um abismo
entre mulheres brancas e mulheres negras
eu tenho o sonho de ver crianças os
heterossexuais aceitando crianças
homossexuais e trânsito de ver mulheres
heterossexuais aceitam mulheres lésbicas
e todos nós que a gente fique muito
atentos para garantir o direito dos
índios
eu queria aqui hoje fazer um convite em
convite pra gente se ajudar muito além
de se ajudar para que todos possam ter
de fato as mesmas possibilidades porque
perante a lei
somos todos iguais mas na prática não
somos isso não é um problema as
diferenças não são um problema desde que
elas não cause desigualdade
para isso aconteceu eu tenho a sensação
de que a gente tem que começar a olhar o
outro golo humanidade
o afeto é um exercício olhar para o
outro com afeta é um exercício e
entender que o outro é fim uma extensão
da gente olha essa gente quiser andar
tranquilamente pelas ruas de dia e de
noite a gente quiser ficar das nossas
casas sem aflição de saber como ou se os
nossos filhos chegaram aos seus destinos
se a gente quer ligar a televisão e não
assistir a uma enxurrada de sangue
se a gente quer andar com os nossos
carros abertos com os vidros abertos não
quiser ficar fazendo contas e pouco será
durante a um carro
a gente vai ter que melhorar a vida das
pessoas é a única maneira de uma chance
disso é a gente olhar para o outro por
certo com atenção e aí fica a pergunta
como é que a gente pode melhorar a vida
das pessoas
o governo lançou uma empresa porque o
governo sério a gente sabe o que ele
deve fazer para acabar com a
desigualdade e deve investir em
políticas públicas de ações afirmativas
em políticas educacionais inclusivas léo
empresa pode reavaliar seu quadro de
funcionários e fazer a diversidade um
pilar real dessa companhia
mas é a sociedade civil o que a
sociedade civil pode fazer
bom nós somos a sociedade civil
e essa tem sido a questão da minha vida
como eu posso melhorar a vida das
pessoas
e aí eu fico pensando que talvez a gente
tenha que transformar os nossos
pensamentos e nossas falas em ação e
entender que as ações individuais
ela gera impacto diretamente no coletivo
e o coletivo somos nós somos a nossa
sociedade
as pequenas ações elas são valiosas e
elas são capazes de mudar o mundo e onde
começa o mundo assinou loja vejo
obrigado
[Aplausos]